If then you have been raised with Christ,
seek the things that are above where Christ is seated at the right hand of God.
Set your minds on things that are above, not on things that are on earth
For you have died and your life is hidden with Christ in God.
When Christ who is your life appears,
then you will also appear with him in glory.
Well, good morning again, church. It's always great to see you, to be together,
to worship like this. If you're new to our church, uh, my name's John.
I'm one of the pastors here. Uh,
we're honored that you would choose to be here with us today. Uh,
we'd love to get to know you and get to meet you somehow. Uh,
there's a QR code and one of the seat backs right in front of you.
Or you can grab one of those cards, fill it out,
take it to the new here area out there. We'd love to just bless you and help,
help you connect here if we can. Uh, we are thankful you're here.
We hope you are welcome, uh, and, and encouraged by your time with us.
We're continuing a series from the book of Colossians called Christ. Above All,
we've been talking about how Christ is superior to all worldly philosophies and
even superior to sin and temptation. As we get into this today,
though, what I want to tell you a little bit about is my experience with getting
completely off of social media About six months ago, all Facebook, Instagram,
Twitter, everything. I was completely off of that. And, and listen,
I don't share that with you to impress you. Uh, it is something,
or even that you should do that too. My my point in sharing that is that my, uh,
my experience has been kind of negative in that way.
I'm saying this as a negative illustration. In other words,
I'm sharing that because to my shame, uh, as I went off of social media,
my mind as I look at the last six months is much freer now, uh,
that it's less, uh, fomo, right? Fear of missing out.
Like I'm just wondering what am I not hearing about than I'm less focused on
what kids, uh, in, in your family are doing or less focused on,
uh, what perfect vacation you might have had or,
or how you're feeling about the President right now?
Like I'm less focused on all those things. My mind is freer.
But here's what that revealed.
It revealed that for so many years without realizing it,
my mind was,
was easily sucked into the things here on earth
rather than the things that are in heaven, eternal, good,
godly things. Now,
you might be feeling that in your life right now.
It may not be social media for you,
it might be Fox News or c n n depending on which you pick or,
or maybe it's fantasy football.
Maybe it's your kids' sports
or golfing or relationship or hunting or gaming or
a perfect wardrobe or, or whatever.
It could be literally anything else.
What we're looking for in all of those things is identity.
We're looking for an identity,
something to identify with that gives us worth or value or, or we feel affirmed.
And, and affirmation out of that something that makes us feel something. Even
that's why this truth today is so essential to remember that
your new and your true identity is from above,
not from here below.
This is not just for young people to hear today.
This is for all of us to hear that your true best new identity
comes from above, not from here below.
What really matters is found above in heaven, not here below.
And that's what we'll see in this critical transitional section here in the book
of Colossians as we begin chapter three now, as our journey goes through it.
So take your copy of God's Word and turn there with me.
Colossians three verses one through four is where we're gonna be today.
If you remember,
we've seen the apostle Paul has written this letter to the young church in
Colossae to remind them of a few things that Christ is above all the false
religious practices that were so prevalent around them.
And so they should not only trust Christ alone, they can trust Christ alone.
They don't have to drift back into any other religious practices or beliefs.
They don't need any of that because Christ has made them
spiritually alive. He's given them new life through his life,
death and resurrection. So he's enough,
the whole book of Colossians to remind them of that. Look how he now continues.
A bit of a transition here. Chapter three, verses one through four.
If then you have been raised with Christ, sounds familiar,
now that we've seen it on this, uh, intro video, all series, right? This is it.
If then you have been raised with Christ,
seek the things that are above where Christ is seated
at the right hand of God, set your minds on things that are above,
not on things that are on earth for you have died and
your life is hidden with Christ in God.
When Christ who is your life appears,
then you also will appear with him in glory.
God, help us see clearly what we've heard over and over in this intro video
of this whole series, this passage. God, that this is the crux of the matter.
Show us what you want us to see today. Open our hearts to be challenged,
confronted, changed as we need it.
May we be good soiled. May we be doers of the word, not just hearers only
do your work in us through your word. Give us a life according to your word God,
in Jesus' name. Amen. So again,
as we read through God's word,
whether you're doing it by yourself or we're doing it here,
we look for markers like transition words and commands.
Those are helping us understand what is important,
how things fit together in God's word.
And so there's a couple of 'em right here, right? You see in verse one, the,
then it shows us this sections dependent on what he has just said in the
previous few verses or chapters. And then in verse three,
there's a word four f o r.
It shows us that what he's saying there is the reason to do what he just said.
So he is giving us a lot of framework here for why we should do what
he's telling us to do here.
And so to get the Colossians there and to get us to those commands,
we'll see later he reminded them of four truths of salvation here.
That this short passage,
there's really four big bucket items of salvation. The truth's here.
And we're gonna see 'em very clearly. These are the reasons. What are they?
Well, here's the first one.
The first truth is that Christ was exalted to the throne.
Christ was exalted to the throne.
That's one of the main things we see right here. The end of verse one. It says,
what? Christ is seated at the right hand of God.
Now remember as we've walked through chapter one, especially into chapter two,
we realize and learned that Christ is God.
So how's he sitting in a sense next to God? Well, remember God is trinity.
God is three in one. And so, so technically,
if you're trying to get really detailed, the Father, God,
the Father is sitting on the throne. And God the Son is at his right hand.
Now, what's so important about the right hand? Why is that a big deal?
Is it because 90% of the population is right-handed? Sorry, lefties.
I know those scissors are really tough, but uh, you know what I mean, right?
Is that, is that why they're saying right hand? No.
The right hand of a dignitary signified honor
and authority.
This is actually referring to what is the most quoted Old Testament verse
in the New Testament. It's Psalm 110 Verse one.
David is pre luting the Messiah, looking forward. He says, the Lord,
that's Yahweh says to my Lord,
David's even referencing my Lord,
sit at my right hand till I make your enemies your footstool.
Every time that's used in the New Testament, it's talking about Jesus.
And so this is pointing to God the Father, God the Son, this whole uniqueness.
But it's about authority.
Now you remember where Jesus went after his resurrection after the 40 days of
teaching with his disciples. In Acts one, it shows he did what?
He ascended back to heaven. Where did he go in heaven just to go hang out,
play golf with his buddies? No, he went to the right hand of the throne of God.
He went to this place of honor and authority to rule over
all things.
And so the Colossians needed to hear that again because all this other stuff was
trying to threaten God's authority.
That meant this meant that they didn't need to cater to these lesser
authorities, these lesser powers. They didn't need to try to,
to make them happy too. They just needed to focus on Christ alone.
'cause Christ is over them all. They needed to remember that.
We need to remember that. Listen, church, this God we serve.
He's not powerless. He's powerful.
This is who we serve. God is over all things.
And so we can trust him. Christ was exalted to the throne.
That's important.
Here's the second foundational truth of salvation.
Christians are dead to the world.
What
We see here, Christians are dead to the world.
Look again at verse three.
For you have died and your life is hidden with Christ in God.
Now, this is not the first time we've seen this concept that Christians,
we have died in a sense to the world. We just saw it last week,
chapter two verse 20.
If or since with Christ, you died to the elemental spirits of the world.
Why are you as if you're still alive in the world? Do you submit to regulations?
Right? In other words, what he's saying is that when Christ died to the world,
in a sense, you Christian, you died with him to the world.
You are in his death in that way.
But think of, okay, so what do we mean by that?
What do we mean when this says the Christian has died to the world?
What does that mean?
Does that mean I could just not care anymore about anything?
I can just kind of go through my life and give up all my responsibilities?
Is that what dying to the world means? No.
What have you died to? What did it say?
You've died to the elemental spirits of the world that is
referencing those functional saviors that they were getting tempted by in
Colossae, the same functional saves that you and I set up in our daily lives.
We've died to that Romans seven, verse six,
you've died to the law that has held us captive. It says
Romans six, two even says You've died to sin. Praise the Lord.
This is what we mean when we say Christians are dead to the world.
That it's no longer where we're trying to find salvation.
We're trying to find worth eternal value.
We don't need it here anymore.
And those Colossians needed to hear that because they were being tempted to
dilute the gospel and to spin off into all these other false
religions. Paul says, guys,
you're dead to all that. You don't need that.
Listen, we need to hear it today too 'cause, 'cause like I said, we,
we create functional saviors all the time in our own lives.
This is going to make me satisfied. This is gonna get me to heaven all. No, no,
we're dead to all of those things.
But the counter truth to that of course is that if you've died with Christ,
that means you are also raised with Christ.
If you are in him and he's died, then if you're in him, he's also raised.
So you are raised with him. In fact,
that's what verse one says. I said this last week,
that word if at the beginning of verse one can actually be since,
because it's a condition assumed to be true, right? If you've been raised, no,
since you've been raised with Christ, seek the things that are above.
So this is assumed to be true,
that you have already been raised with Christ.
But then notice something else in verses three and four Again, see,
if you hear a repeated word in these two verses,
for you have died and your life is hidden with Christ in God,
when Christ who is your life appears,
then you also will appear with him in glory.
So I know Christ is repeated in there, but what else is repeated? Life?
Your life that's said over and over. So you died.
You died, but now you are alive in Him.
Your new life. It says it's hidden with Christ in God,
meaning it's secure, it's safe.
Not only that, verse four said something even further. It said,
Christ is your life.
So, so God's not up there just sustaining your physical life.
He also is your very spiritual life.
In other words too, the Colossians Paul is saying, Hey,
you don't need to to find identity in all these religious systems or behaviors.
You don't need to turn back to worthless, dead,
useless philosophies in the world to try to gain anything.
Why? Because you're alive in Christ. Now,
don't try to find life any other way.
You're already alive. You have life.
That life is in him. It's according to his word. Psalm 19 says,
and man, this is most likely,
the biggest problem our society has today,
is that we are looking for life everywhere.
And as hard as people try, as
much as we search out better pleasures,
better cars, bigger houses,
a new spouse, political victories, whatever it is,
it will not satisfy,
it will not give you life,
and it will only cause you further heartache when you do put
your hope and your joy and your identity in all those kind of things.
Because here's what the enemy does. He takes all of those,
the the futility of all of those things, and he takes it all. And he,
he steals your joy with it. He kills your ability to find life with it.
He destroys your foundation with it.
That's what the enemy came. Jesus said it, John 10 10, the thief,
the enemy comes only to steal and kill and destroy.
And remember who's in charge of the worldly ways right now.
The enemy is the enemy is running. He's wreaking havoc. He's,
he's just wrecking everything as much as he can in the world around us.
So why are we trying to find life in this stuff that he's doing that with
Jesus? Didn't stop. The thief comes to steal, kill, and destroy.
What else did he say? He says, but I have come. Jesus says,
I have come that they may have life and not just
any life.
Life abundantly abundant life.
That's what we're looking for, right? We're looking for abundant life.
We want this, this satisfying life.
We're looking for it in all of these wrong places.
Instead of looking for the one who is your life, Colossians three,
four says,
there's one more truth of salvation here in this passage.
It's in verse four.
It's that Christ is returning to his kingdom.
Christ is returning to his kingdom. Look at it again. Verse four.
When Christ who is your life appears,
then you also will appear with him in glory.
Now,
this is not making a statement in any kind about how or when Jesus will
physically bodily return. It's just saying that he will.
It's saying that he will appear
Because in some way, the king is hidden right now, right?
The throne and the the son sitting at the father's right hand, he's, he's hid.
We can't see that he's, it's hidden for now,
but also think a layer deeper.
He's also hidden spiritually in a way where not everyone
acknowledges who he is as Lord and Savior.
They don't acknowledge that he is the king right now.
Yet this says all of that will one day be revealed when
Jesus appears.
Yet notice something else
for those who find their life in Christ,
for those who are hidden with Christ in God, it says here,
they will appear with him in glory. Now,
what does that even mean? Well, part of it is that Jesus,
you can see one Thessalonians four, part of what it means is that Jesus,
when he returns,
he's bringing with him all of the believers who've died prior to that moment.
So we, if we're still alive, wouldn't be brought back.
But all those who would be will appear with him in glory.
That's part of this.
Part of it is that the process of sanctification will finally be completed on
that day and we will appear. The word is glorified.
Doesn't mean we get glory like Christ gets glory.
It means we are finally finished with this process of becoming like Jesus.
We're not there yet. That's sanctification making us holy.
One day we'll be finished and that's called glorification will be like
Jesus fully in that perfection sins.
So that's part of this as well. But here,
here's another part that you might not catch on the surface.
Part of what will be revealed in glory, you might say,
is that the good that has been hidden in our lives for so long
will finally be revealed for what it is.
It will be honored when Christ appears.
Here's, here's what I mean.
That pure single life that you've chosen to live,
that often gets laughed at by the world,
it will be honored on that day and all will be made
clear that you found your hope and your joy and life in
Christ over anything else here.
The fact that you have been and and not required to but chosen
to,
to set aside so much of what the world can offer in life because you are
serving that special needs child that God gave you
that will be honored on the day Jesus appears.
Because you chose things that are above,
not things that are on earth, and the way you did it,
the way you journeyed that pathway,
the Lord will say, look, this is what is good.
The way you walk faithfully through cancer,
the way you walk faithfully and and in a kind, gentle way,
when a business partner turns their back on you,
it'll be honored.
It'll be shown to be what it is that you placed your hope and your life in
things above, not on things this earth can offer.
And on and on and on and on we could go.
Here's what Paul was saying to the Colossians. What he's saying to us is like,
Hey, it might seem like you're outnumbered.
It might seem like you're pushed aside for dying to the world and finding life
in Christ. Just know the day is coming when all will be made right?
All will be shown to be what it is. All will be glory one day.
That's what second Corinthians four says so well verses
16 through 18. So we do not lose heart,
though our outer self is wasting away.
Our inner self is being renewed day by day
for this light,
momentary affliction is preparing for us an eternal weight
of glory beyond all comparison as we look,
not to the things that are seen,
but to the things that are unseen for the things that are seen.
All the stuff in the world are transient, temporary,
but the things that are unseen are eternal.
So we don't lose heart
when you walk a road that's hard and that I've just described in some various
ways all over the,
and you're just being faithful and you think nobody sees you're getting cast off
by the world because of it. No, the day is coming. So don't lose heart.
That's in fact how the Colossians were to respond to these four truths.
Okay? We've seen these truths. Paul's laid these truths out. Okay,
what do they do with that? How do we respond in our lives?
Well,
Let me read again all of these four verses and you'll see how it all fits
together. Now,
Since you have been raised with Christ,
seek the things that are above where Christ is seated at the right hand of God.
Set your minds on things that are above,
not on things that are on earth because you have died and your life is hidden
with Christ in God. When Christ who is your life appears,
then you also will appear with him in glory.
And so he's saying, guys,
what are you to do now with this new identity that you have?
What are you to do now with the fact that you've been raised with Christ?
What do you do with that? First,
keep looking for the kingdom of God.
Keep looking for it for this kingdom
since you've been raised with Christ,
since you already in God, spiritually in Christ.
Seek the things that are above
like you're ultimately looking for Christ. You're looking for His kingdom.
And remember where Christ is, where is Christ? He is above.
He's seated at the right hand of the Father on heavens throne.
And so he's saying, you are to seek those heavenly things.
Seek the things that are true of Christ.
That word to seek means keep on desiring to
possess it. Now look for it.
Look for the ways God is working in this world already
and keep working for the ways he would show up through your life on a
daily basis. It's not just sitting back and kinda watching.
It's actually participating to see it now,
to desire to possess it now because
he's already the king. We are already a part of his kingdom.
We already have a new set of values.
We are to live those things out here today on this earth.
'cause our true citizen here, listen, our true citizenship is not here.
It's hidden with Christ in God there.
That's our true home.
I read this illustration this week. So imagine,
imagine you're getting ready to move to Japan next month,
and so you've got all the, the itinerary, the flights, everything you're,
you're gonna move to Japan in a couple weeks.
You would naturally set your mind on the things of Japan,
right? Like you'd start now going ahead to start learning how to eat sushi.
You would figure out how to begin learning the language.
You might even learn how to do sumo wrestling. I don't know. Maybe, maybe not.
But you, you figure out how to live like think. Think of this.
You would seek to live today the way you know you're about to live permanently.
Is that not what we're talking about here? If that's home,
if that's permanent, that's what this is saying.
Even the midst of darkness. In the midst of the hard ships of life,
since we're hidden with Christ and God,
since we are already there in a sense with him,
we are to do what Colossians two six said a couple weeks ago. Therefore,
as you received Christ, Jesus the Lord. So walk in him.
You already have him. You are already there. He's already yours.
You already his. And so walk it out, live it out.
Here's the reality though. You know it's true. Every study says it's true.
Sadly, many Christians
live no differently than the world we live in right here.
No substantial statistical difference between the way Christians live their
lives here versus unbelievers all around us.
This is what we're supposed to be. Citizens of heaven. New value,
new kingdom people. Well, here's the good news.
The rest of Colossians will show us what that looks like.
What does a new kingdom life look like?
It'll help us grasp what it should look like for us as
believers. But here's the truth.
You can only look for and you can only work for the
kingdom of God coming here as Jesus prayed in Matthew five.
You can only do all that first if you are thinking about the kingdom of God.
It's one thing to say, all right, go live it, work it.
You gotta think about it first. And that's verse two.
That's that's my illustration I started with about the way my mind was stolen
away to social media and all these things like that's what we're talking about
here. It's verse two,
set your minds on things that are above,
not on things that are on earth.
Like there's no explanation needed that is just straight up clear.
But listen, think about that.
If our Lord and Savior is there,
if our life is there,
and if we have died to all the things here,
then why would we prioritize anything but him?
Anything but that he's there. Our life is there. He is our,
why would we prioritize all the things we have died to?
The Colossians,
they were tempted to think about all this religious noise that kept coming their
way, the sin options that were all over colossae that, so Paul,
what did he say? He said, give careful attention.
Give full focus to the things that are above,
not to these things.
'cause he knew that would keep them from getting sucked away to all of that
stuff. The falsehoods, everything sinful.
It's the same battle for us today, church.
And actually in some ways it's even harder for us
when you think about the pervasiveness of our phones,
computers, tv,
all the noise that we choose to allow into our lives just
constantly bombarding us.
And it is much harder to think about the kingdom of God,
to think about things that are above when we're constantly thinking about all of
these other things.
Your brain can only think about one thing at one time. No, I can multitask. No,
you're task switching really quickly.
You can only think about one thing at one time.
And so if we're constantly thinking about all of these other things,
we're not thinking about the kingdom of God, the things that are above.
And remember, where's your new identity? It's above, not below.
And yet we make it so much harder on ourselves to
remember what that true identity actually is
when you're sitting there constantly comparing yourself, your body, whatever,
to that influencer on TikTok,
when you're immersed
nonstop into this political spin cycle that we live in,
when you spend 10 times the amount of time on
stat sheets for your fantasy team than you do in the word of God,
when you're spending hours searching through house listings to find that perfect
neighborhood.
Now listen, I don't want us to go back.
We talked about this last week about going back to these manmade rules
and regulation.
'cause I could sit up here and I could just start firing stuff off at you. Now,
this is what you need to do. You need to get rid of this, right?
You need to bury your tv. Remember that one. You need to get rid of your phone,
get off of social media. Like I could sit here and impose these things on you.
Absolutely. But listen, that's cutting away branches. Remember?
But here, listen, I do think
that you need to ask the Lord for wisdom on this in your life.
I, I can't impose something on you. Nobody should.
But you need to ask the Lord for wisdom here,
and you need to ask him to expose your heart where you are.
Treasuring things here
that you might need to remove or might need to limit in your life.
Do you need to make some hard decisions
so that you can better set your mind on things that are above,
not on things that are on earth,
so that you can get to the root of the sin easier so you can
let God change you easier? Do you need to make some hard decisions?
Ask the Lord for that 'cause.
Psalm 1914, praise.
Let the words of my mouth and the meditation of my heart be
acceptable in your sight. Oh Lord, my rock, my redeemer.
What's the meditation of your heart? That's the things you are thinking about.
What kind of things should you think about? Philippians four, eight says,
finally, brothers, whatever is true, whatever is honorable,
whatever is just, whatever is pure, whatever is lovely, whatever is commendable,
if there's any excellence, if there's anything worthy of praise,
think about these things.
Set your mind on these
Things.
One more thing to remember today, though
I,
We've talked a lot about things on heaven, things in heaven, things on earth.
You know what else is on earth?
You know what else is something that you have died to. If you are in Christ
Your sin,
Romans six, you have died to your
Sin.
Hear me? The enemy loves to keep bringing it up,
to bring you down.
He loves tossing it back in your mind,
to keep you ineffective in living out this new kingdom kind of life,
this heavenly focused kind of life. But do not forget, this is the gospel.
Do not forget that Christ has already defeated that record of debt that's
against you because you didn't do it right. You didn't obey the law. It's gone,
it's defeated it. The death of Christ,
who then also made you alive together with him.
He's forgiven you of all of that.
You are dead to that sin. You in Christ,
you've died to all of that. You've been raised with Christ. Your life is hidden,
safely, securely in God.
So how do you respond? That's what Romans six continues with,
verses 11 through 13. So you also must consider mean.
You must choose to believe it,
that you are dead to sin and alive to God in Christ Jesus.
Remind yourself, keep telling yourself then let not sin. Therefore,
reign in your mortal body to make you obey its passions.
Don't present your members to sin as instruments of unrighteousness,
but present yourselves to God as those who've been brought from death to
life. Don't give yourself to sin anymore.
You're dead to it. You are alive to God.
So give yourself to God that he can use it for righteousness sake.
Stop letting the shame of your past, the sin,
the temptation that the enemy tosses your way.
Stop letting it all derail you from following Christ. You're dead to it all now.
It's like that snake, you cut its head off,
it still thrashes around for a while. That's your sin. That's the enemy.
He's that defeated,
but he's still fighting and he's trying to what? Steal,
kill, and destroy everything in your life.
He's dead. You're dead to it.
So stop focusing on it. Stop thinking about it. Stop setting your mind on it.
Here's what an old pastor once said, he said, for every one, look at yourself.
Take 10 looks at Christ. You've gotta know,
you've gotta acknowledge, yes, I'm a sinner. Yes, I blew that one.
But set your mind on things that are above. Take 10 looks at Christ.
Look back to the gospel. Don't forget who he is and what he's done.
The more you do that,
the more you remember what he says over what the world says.
That's where your identity is secure in him.
It's where you're not worried about what everybody else is doing,
what things are happening around you. You are secure in him,
and that's how you more consistently live out Christ's new
kingdom principles here on earth.
Set your mind on things that are above.
Seek the things that are above where your
life is.